tell you what's crazy bloomberg news I
just I just did a segment on this
earlier today from my other channel
Bloomberg News shut down a story on the
Chinese Communist Chinese Communist
Party members and in the internal
recordings that were released to NPR
they were saying that they were straight
up calling China Nazis and they were
like let's have no illusions about it we
know what they are
Wow then these press organ at these news
organizations they get killed the story
they knew so they had some dirt
eventually the New York Times released
the story they had some dirt on how
these communist party members made money
and they said if we report this we risk
being kicked out of the country and we
sell terminals there so we better not do
it I don't be very careful that's the
gist of the story yeah although they
claim that it wasn't fully vetted and
that's what they always do we'd love to
report on this but we don't know if we
have enough Infernus spare me did you
you you were bending the knee to the
Chinese Communist Party that you called
Nazis you said let's have no illusions
about it you know what they are yeah and
no one will do anything about it
remember remember the NBA dude What did
he say
Steve Kerr he's like whoa no one over
there talked to me about our gun
violence and people were like dude are
you kidding me Oh spare oh yeah I
remember reading that like are you
kidding me so so you need so that's it
that's a very good point to be made mr.
NBA that because some crazy people
randomly commit acts of violence that
somehow justifies ignoring the
concentration camps full of people
having their organs harvested excellent
point sir that's good that's why I'm
saying it when when you look at what's
going on with those camps yeah as human
rights violations it's messed up I'm Way
beyond it you're right you know one of
the craziest things that I was reading
was that there were apparently like rich
people getting lung transplants you know
cuz you get scar tissue from the krona
virus this is all rumor I don't I don't
have any sources pulled up to take it
all the grain of salt but someone on
Twitter said I wonder where the lungs
are coming from for these transplants
handy so this so one of the one of the
theories that's going around is that
there are certain countries where
they're Muslim and so they need they
can't have non like what is it called
halal hello yeah but if you have these
concentration camps in China where they
are harvesting organs these are Muslims
so their organs are hollow
so that means they can essentially sell
the organs to high paying individuals
who want clean organ transplants that's
just another thing I see that I see
journalists talking about that on
Twitter I don't know if that's true
we're gonna say I was gonna say seven
days ago China was appointed to the UN
Human Rights Council just thought that
was yeah and that's so messed up hey ma
I don't understand
you know what I'll put it this way I'm
actually really concerned about China's
expansion their growth their economy
yeah and it gives me pause they might
they might win a potential you know
conflict especially when you consider
that our economy is totally crippled
right now we don't make they make our
medicine totally we got to remember that
they have us at a complete disadvantage
right now and not not in military
strength but in every other way way Yeah
right
I mean well they've been siphoning off
our resources exactly so I think there's
a possibility but you know what there is
nothing that would ever make me to say
I'm gonna place my chips on China
I'd be like even if I thought China
would win with a great probability I'd
like I'll put everything on America you
mother we're going down with the ship
captain stays in the ship
I will sink down and I will give this
loot as a ship goes down to the ocean I
will not bend the knee to communists
never gonna happen which which you know
now that we're seeing with the
coronavirus lockdown how authoritarian
things are getting here you know I'm not
happy about that we were mentioning
earlier yeah yeah we've got what's going
on in in Michigan can't buy seeds yeah
can't buy seeds gardening work like
can't protest yeah no I love the protest
anymore dude
III wonder if we're on the precipice I
know I know a lot of people it's
interesting because there'll be a lot of
people who messaged me saying like you
don't understand how close we are to war
and they'll send me all these stories
then I get other people's enemy stories
saying oh nothing's gonna happen you
have no idea you're talking about you
know why I don't know man I'm just gonna
think I'm just gonna talk about how I
see it and what I think and I'm not sure
we're actually at that point yet but it
seems like over the past I don't know
seven years or longer than that but I
mean seven years since I was being you
know seeing all the stuff more
prominently that we've been close to
something for a long time but nobody
wants to be the you know
be the first person to fire that shot
heard around the world yeah yeah you and
I were talking about war with China in
October because you're the trade war
stuff oh yeah
could not have predicted this but yeah
it's really interesting how it's all
China centric even the virus you know
who really talked about China a lot
there's a certain man who everyone used
to make fun of him for years Donald
Trump yep 2015 man 2011 he's been
talking I pulled up I pulled up been
talking about China for so long about
how big of a problem they are and
everyone all they did was just make fun
of him for talking about her early on it
like before was running for president
they didn't really make fun of him now a
lot of these articles were alike Trump
said this yeah as soon as he runs for
president though they real it dude the
media would would look the joke is that
if Trump came out in favor of oxygen
they'd hold their breath Brad so that
but there was another joke and and this
is hilarious Trump supporters have said
if Trump cured cancer they would find a
way to make it negative Trump literally
comes out with like hey a bunch of
countries are using hydroxychloroquine
this is very hopeful it might not work
but I'm hopeful and the media comes out
against it substantial
yes seriously you know is the crazy
thing is this this doctor on Twitter
tweeted two stories both from the
Washington Post and one said Trump
pedals false hope over
hydroxychloroquine blah blah blah the
next story was Gili ads patented REMS de
vie or whatever it's called what is it
called intensive air from Des of air is
showing hope and it's like hmm the
patented controlled major pharmaceutical
drug is good and the generic that Trump
touted is bad very bad makes you wonder
doesn't it yeah yeah I don't honestly
the more and more I am privy to this
media world political realm that I
wasn't really paying attention to before
the more I see the media seems to be
whoever is the highest bidder and it's
sometimes it feels like it's China
sometimes it feels like it's
pharmaceutical companies but either way
they're there they don't care about the
truth that's what I've known for sure
it's I would I would liken it to maybe
like a swarm of piranhas in a toilet
oh okay so they will go after that there
in a swarm they typically don't attack
each other but they might okay and so
what what ends up happening is there's I
can't pinpoint anything that seems to
guide what this machine is and aside
from the fact that some of the people in
media are activists total activists yeah
but then you have people like Jim Acosta
he is the perfect example of everything
Trump complains about and it was it was
funny there was an ex a former former
scene and producer wrote this newsletter
for the first network it's called then
it's a network called the first and he
basically said if you told me Jim Acosta
was secretly working for the Trump
reelection campaign I'd believe it some
that something that vector because he's
like look at what Jim Acosta does he's a
caricature of everything trump complains
about stands up is really annoying and
then tees up Trump to give this epic
shutdown response every time it's true
you're right he gets up and he's like
well you know you're you're not helping
people and then shungiku am I not
helping well I mean he's like I caught
you you're fake news you see now you
look at all the people so Jim Acosta
will say something really terrible yeah
and then give Trump an opportunity to to
say exactly what he's doing right it's
the craziest thing yes and then and then
what's really fun is they point out Jim
Acosta 'he's twitter banner is him on
jimmy kimmel
he's like Jim Acosta just wants to be
famous so all of these people impress
now in in the media industry
particularly the political media so here
because it's not all journalists
obviously it's mostly the political ones
I don't think they actually care about
Trump at all I agree you know what makes
the least about a sense to me why is it
that all of these outlets rag on Fox
News all day every day like CNN and
Media Matters for instance right wing
watch Fox News is one cable channel out
of how many news channels are there
dozens I know I do if they're like we
don't like Fox because Fox says opinions
we don't like look when a bunch of
people are ragging on CNN CBS NBC ABC
the near Times Washington Post you keep
going you're like oh that's a ton of
different no you know companies it's a
major industry and it includes political
you know politics are across the
spectrum I understand that I understand
if someone comes out and says all of
these big media companies keep pushing
this narrative it's not true
you're complaining that the entire
of media is biased yeah it makes no
sense to single out one network and
scream about it all day every night it's
the weirdest thing I don't make videos
about scene on all that often I do talk
about them but typically in this context
when you talk about something like that
it makes people want to watch them
you're giving them free advertising I
don't you know the weirdest thing
Brian brian Stelter the the CNN media
guy him and Oliver Darcy the other media
guy all they do like over the past
couple days is like tweet what foxnews
is doing and I'm like I don't I don't
understand is am I supposed to not like
what you're saying what's the point your
talent you're giving me a play-by-play
of Fox News I can turn it on right now I
don't need to follow you on twitter yeah
like what but people in the in the
replies were angry about the things they
were tweeting and it it's just right
over my head I'm like I don't understand
so like one of them was Trump says I
have the sole power to open up the
economy right and it says judge it says
you know Fox News Chiron the banner
Trump says he can open his soul power to
open the economy then the next tweeted
section says Judge Napolitano says
that's not true the states do then the
next section says Fox changes banner to
who can open the who has the power up
the economy and I'm like but that's
normal
Trump said it was him all time said no
so then you know that the title of the
segment to give you information was they
were challenging who has the real
authority brian Stelter tweeted that
from CNN as if it was like a negative
and all of these resistance people in
the comments were like I can't believe
FoxNews would do that and phone news and
of course they're lying and I'm like
they literally didn't know anything like
I'm just reporting it as it comes that's
the that's the crazy thing like ah that
makes sense to me the other dude Oliver
Darcy was tweeting about it and he's
like look at what CNN put and CNN's low
earth like the Chiron the banner was
like they were having a meltdown it was
like you know Trump has angry outbursts
trying to rewrite history and I'm like
whoa whoa and then he's like and here's
what Fox News is doing and Fox was just
a trump quote it was like Trump says in
a quote like that's what it's supposed
to be yeah I was surprised
CNN people retweeting their Chiron's
they're like this is what we're talking
about like you realize how this makes
you look right they're nuts
what does yeah
I don't know they're like in what world
is this good you're opinionated on
everything yeah that's why I tweeted I
like the news you gotta like look
through the weave do it yes see oh it's
it's actually not CNN it's another news
source yeah why don't I just go there
for me
did you see but you ended up seen when
I'm with Chris Cuomo a little bit you
know me I did a segment on earlier he he
likes synapse apparently on his radio
show he's like I have no value I see no
value in what I'm doing I don't want to
do this it's like I don't want to peddle
in things I think are ridiculous he like
slammed the hyper-partisan nation nature
of the networks he said that's awesome
he would never beat John Hannity or
Rachel Maddow and I feel like he's
saying that ratings or ratings okay cuz
he's their top show he's like okay but
he gets like eight hundred thousand
viewers per day mihran way more than
that on YouTube granted CNN gets
hundreds of millions on youtube I don't
I act like I'm getting more than CNN
yeah but he went off handy like he
actually recently you know like a few
hours later was like no no I don't mean
it I like my job please don't fire me
huh he didn't say please I'm fine he was
like I like what I'm doing but I think
he snapped because CNN used to be news
like do you remember you turn it on and
they would be like we're on the ground
in Louisiana or yeah he likes reporting
he likes being a reporter he likes you
know talking to the masses but he
doesn't like what they're forcing him to
do yeah that's what it seems like but
you know what he said he's like I saved
up a bunch of money now so I don't care
it's like I wish you would have had
scruples before yeah like it's really
easy to be like I got paid four million
dollars a year for the past five years
I'm gonna quit it's like now that you
and your family are rich forever now
you're ready to quit this is called
quitting that's not principal that's
just quitting Yeah right
but now Perry you not well no he doesn't
want to quit I guess he changed his tune
but but I think what he's saying it's
actually we saw the project project
Veritas you you know they are they did
undercover footage of regular CNN
employees saying things like we used to
news we used to go on the ground we used
to like we used to have a guy he'd be
like hey I'm here on scene they don't do
it anymore it's all panels yeah I bet if
we turned it on right now at the orange
man Bette
not even kidding I agree so they're all
or coronavirus right right now you see
he does have with me politician man has
worsened coronavirus I think you exactly
but you uh what we're seeing now with
Chris Cuomo is it's made to the top yeah
like first you have the the low-level
producers being like I'm not happy with
what I'm doing yeah he actually even
said he's tired of analyzing the
president he's like who we all know is
full of s anyway fine and I'm like yeah
okay and like you like he snapped yeah
that was it like CNN has become just the
trash network and everyone knows it and
this was like he accidentally pulled the
curtain aside you can see behind all the
inner workings in your life man oh man
they all know what they're doing side
source yeah we can all see it now I mean
the public knows you guys are full of a
mess yeah we don't swear on this show I
try not to yeah but in fact it is kind
of refreshing to see someone in such a
high position in the media kind of like
blows top a little like oh yeah I'm
pissed and everyone's like yeah we know
we see it thank you
we're admitting it what's actually sad
is that when he did this I think the
reason a lot of people are reacting in
the way they are to it is because we all
knew it yeah exactly you could see it in
his eyes when he's standing there and
he's like twitching like having to say
something that makes no sense
what like or being a network with Don
Lemon so the New York Times actually
barred their reporters from appearing on
Don lemons show briefly because I said
it was partisan and Don Lemon gentleman
I am NOT partisan no I'm a reporter and
then he just goes on as you know our
long rant about the president being bad
all day every day it's like dude I don't
think you get it
like if so so Donald Trump did this
press briefing where he rag Don all the
journalists and they got really angry
and that's where CNN did these this
meltdown tantrum in their banner and I'm
like if you want to report the news and
Trump is insulting you you you're the
bottom the group the graphic card should
be something like Trump criticizes the
press during press briefing like not
hyper loaded language you tell people
what he's doing he's criticizing the
press yeah they make it personal right
can be very simple yeah just say it boom
but because he's targeted all bias about
it they take it personally yeah and
their ego gets bruised and so they say
Trump is a narcissist who's rewriting
history and they and they don't realize
Trump is baiting them yeah it seems like
it like it's it's almost like you ever
see if the movie next with with Nicolas
Cage I know I haven't I really like this
movie he can see really you like it yeah
I'll see it
I like this cage it's it's guilty puck
you can see the future he can see like a
couple minutes in the future right
interesting okay so there's the scene
and trust me this makes sense you'll get
it
there's Denard spoil in the movie are
you know it but it's it's one scene in
the beginning I mean the movies like
it's the video anyway hey I don't care
he's sitting at a diner right all right
and he looks over and he sees his
beautiful woman mm-hmm and then he gets
up and he goes and talks to her and then
I guess like her boyfriend shows up and
because he can see the future the
boyfriend goes to swing at him he ducks
and then knocks the dude out and then
the woman goes you dick - John - Nicolas
Cage and she's like how dare you when
she goes to her boyfriend I'm so sorry I
can't believe he hit you and then all of
a sudden it rewinds that was his vision
of the future uh-huh so he's still
sitting there
he gets up walks over talks to her then
the dude walks in the diner and when the
dude goes to hit him he goes here we go
and he lets the dude hit him yeah and
then the woman yells at the boyfriend
and then apologizes Nicolas Cage because
he was the victims like I'm so sorry
that he hit you as a co it's okay wait
so the reason I bring that up is it
feels like that's what Trump does
sometimes okay where he'll tee up the
press to take the bait yeah and then
what happens is like Trump will poke
them and then all of a sudden you walk
in the room and you see the journalists
screeching and yelling and screaming the
president you're like whoa that dude
looks crazy yeah what would happen Trump
and Trump's like they're nuts yeah
you're like must be so you actually saw
it with that uh it almost feels like
they're both I mean both sides of it are
trying to get each other to do that now
totally right yep the press wants the
ratings yeah because they'll take Trump
out of context showing him going like
you look over and they do it all the
time
yeah but I don't think Trump does it on
purpose I think Trump gets baited and
gets angry in so it's insulting them
then they take it personally in turn and
it really just depends on who you like
or don't like more yeah and because
Democrats tend to trust the media they
view Trump as
bad and because conservatives don't
trust the media they view the press is
bad and then for me as somebody who
worked in media and knows the press is
lying yeah I'm like I know what they're
doing the Trump I see it they're lying
so it's not about me liking Trump or not
I'll tell you what though I can't stand
most of these journalists because I've
worked around them for so much they're
the snootiest elitists like you'll ever
meet not all of them a lot of them
there's not a really cool journalist the
real journalists they're not the ones on
TV yeah you know like Brian Kerr
emerging Mecosta those are the
showboaters the real journalists are
behind the scenes and don't want to be
involved they're cool people so what do
you think that these journalists are
gonna say when they start talking about
how Trump freezes the US funds for the
whu-oh oh they're already saying it
they're already saying like unhinged
rant from the president they're saying
someone tweeted Donald Trump you know
Donald Trump suspending funding to the
World Health Organization during a
pandemic is like stop us now it would be
like halting shipments of ammunition to
your allies in a world war and my
response was like maybe if that Ally was
feeding you disinformation which allowed
your adversary to you know didn't slow
you down and kill your people right it
might cut off funding to them yeah every
single person that has mentioned whu-oh
in my Twitter feed anything that I've
seen is there they're like a little
puppet of China China's puppet Wired
magazine everybody is saying this bug
myself like it seems like that's the
case it's like so this makes total sense
to me that trumps like I'm gonna free
they seem like they're you know working
for the Chinese government I'm gonna
freeze holding water running with a
holding water form at least like not
working for him but rice you know
carrying water precisely yeah there was
a story from wired and it said that it
was a right wing stunt to blame the
World Health Organization but it said
Trump and she was like Trump it was like
the right is not wrong about the World
Health Organization and I'm like or said
Trump is not wrong and I'm like you can
just say he's right yes they they can't
do it wired actually said the World
Health Organization has been feeding us
miss disinformation which has slowed our
response down yeah and they called it
they still maintain the only reason the
right was the only reason that the right
was actually saying it was because it
was a stunt maybe it's because the right
and people like me and other you know
politically homeless individuals we see
what's actually happening and we say
it's happening but because the media
lives in this weird bubble where
everything is viewed to the lens of and
every every Republican is evil
they're like certainly this must be fake
news we must say the opposite I think
this is what bothers me most about the
Talking Heads like Don Lemon and Jim
Acosta and everybody are you not
supposed to have a really big pinch of
skepticism when you're a journalist
because that's what I don't see in those
people and I imagine that sits well
behind this is a good time I love how it
to these people the US government can
only be wrong and the Chinese government
our bastions of truth and honor yeah I
don't get it what'd ya get that vibe
from someone and I'm like I'm not gonna
trust anything you say anymore yeah
that's it and I have a feeling that a
lot of people out there feel that exact
same way the United States government
has done a bunch of really awful things
and lied about it yeah and they do all
the time
and I am NOT a big fan of trusting them
I'll tell you what though if the US
government came out and said listen we
got a pandemic we need you to stay home
I'd be like well I don't trust you for
the most part but I'm gonna listen yeah
if the Chinese government came out and
said it I'd be like I will do nothing
that you say I do not believe you and I
think you're trying to hurt me and lo
and behold they are yeah yeah so we're
getting all this disinfo people are
dying even BuzzFeed reported that the
Chinese trolls on social media were
trying to slow the responses in other
countries like Spain and Taiwan I'm like
well well there you go man yeah they're
actively hurting us and they're claiming
the the help they're sending out it they
these countries you see these videos
going out of like Chinese like I don't
know reporters or something saying you
know without the Chinese government all
these other countries would be yea in
dire straits so bless the Chinese
government is like what even even
American journalists are doing it and
then in the next that you know the next
day it's like turns out all this Chinese
equipment doesn't work
where's so not only are they you know
the cause well supposedly the cause we
don't know interesting factor the
contributing factor to the pandemic but
they're sending out faulty stuff yep and
then now we're hearing like they wanted
it to spread in other places and then
when when Putin sends milk medical aid
mm-hmm the press says that it's a
propaganda effort Trump is accepting
Heights like dude you know man thanks
for checking out this clip from the Tim
cast IRL podcast we do the show live
Monday through Friday at 8 p.m. if you
want to catch the full show tune into
this channel subscribe hit the like
button or check us out on iTunes and
Spotify and we will soon have this
podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you